imagine we live in a world now where
you know you ca you can videotape at any
moment
you know you can you know the world is
connected that way
you can't really you know imagine trying
to murder somebody it would be very
difficult right but my point is is that
um
like we get videos of like karen's
right like a jamba juice or whatever
every day now
right but now imagine the
billions of karen moments that were
untaped
under undocumented right yeah and they
were just hearsay
hey did you hear what see what linda
said linda was acting all crazy saying
that she won't worm
you know imagine there was a time where
like
karen's went free crazy but but did
did it did it take the exposure of
carrots and seeing it on social media
for you to believe that there
were that many that existed because i
always knew they were around you see it
everything
hit him from karen's i've never even
really run into a cairn before oh gosh
really come on
airport there's so many no no everyday
life no because i would have to because
i'm so
i would have to be in the midst of a
karen's
outbreak i would be i would have to be
the the catalyst
to get a karen to go and because i'm so
mischievous
and quiet and also underground right
that i
when i'm around in public places i i try
to avoid
like [ __ ] up situations i think i can
read when a situation is about to happen
or
when i see a person you know just i just
not just white people but generally
some white people where i just kind of
go this is going to be an incident like
i told you about like so that you racial
profile the white people
well no like you know i told you about
what that was going to be an incident
yeah like you know like when i was at a
i was at a hotel once
right and a white groundskeeper yeah
you know i you know how i dress i i
dress um
sometimes i dress um dystopian
what's a groundskeeper yeah
it was it was he was a white man who was
in charge of the groundskeeper
he was a groundskeeper like uh like uh
the only groundskeeper i know is from
harry potter no he drew drove around in
a golf cart he wore
green a green like from top to bottom
one thing so he it was obviously
had something to do with telling
basically telling mexicans
go trim that okay god oh jesus i know
who you are
you drove me into that i get it now you
drove me into that
he's the boss man basically the manager
of a landscaping
i thought he said groundskeeper i
thought it was
like somebody that oversaw like a
mansion
no when you go to a fancy hotel right
where there's a lot of like
lawns and like shrubbery and whatever
they have a probably
they have a guy who's the groundskeeper
okay i love that word now
all right so i'm sitting on a bench in a
hotel in arizona
and i looked dystopian meaning my like
one gene leg was there the other one was
not
okay there's holes in my shirt yeah
right and i think i just woken up i was
having a cigarette and like i had like
my face was drooping
bells those balls i had bell's palsy
right because when i said
stress when i wait no when i wake up not
everything is awake at the same time
i understand that okay it takes
different times so i'm smoking you know
my
face is drooping i look dystopian and i
look like i didn't belong at the hotel
the groundskeeper comes up to me all
right i'm not gonna explain what that is
anymore okay would you like the
definition just no no no no no please
don't all right
and he goes where's your hotel key
like and there was other people around
were there other you know people
drinking coffee and around
you know dignified people people that
look like they belong there
you i go excuse me and he goes
are you staying at the hotel because you
can't stay here you can't be sitting
here
you're if you're not staying at the
hotel i mean mind you now this is a chad
moment
right but i didn't have my [ __ ] phone
on me
right i couldn't tape it so i so i just
gave him my key
i'm staying room this room and i just
walked away yeah right
that could have been a chad karen moment
you know what i mean i guess
yeah but he was acting chatty yeah that
was he was chatting yeah so i could have
taped him
but i avoid this avoided the situation
that make sense or no it no it makes
sense no no try to explain
it because that to me now it doesn't
make sense yeah i
i think that someone is profiling you
based on
the way you appear you're just making an
example how i try to kind of like
squash situations and walk away from it
and not you know
not um put more gasoline on the fire
what i wanted to do
is i will not give you my hotel key
what do you mean like um there's other
[ __ ] people around you're not [ __ ]
asking them for their hotel key so [ __ ]
you you should ask them for his hotel
key where's your hotel key
i'm the groundskeeper we have to keep it
i mean we had the movie theater um chad
and karen hey guys we're gonna take a
quick break to
share one of our favorite sponsors with
you